we are in the East Room having a
remarkable day a special day for us
getting a chance to see this magnificent
building feel the patriotism feel the
sense of of history here and we're
especially glad now to be joined by the
Vice President of the United States
welcome thank you very much and welcome
to the White House
I'm again with North Korea you were
there tell me the impact of being there
and and where you think this conflict is
right now because the president talked
to John Dickerson and characterized the
North Korean leader well it's a very
serious time in the region and it's a
very serious threat to the peace and
stability of our allies and I think as
the president has said again and again
North Korea represents the most serious
security threat in the world and he
wanted me to go there he wanted me to
reaffirm our commitment to South Korea
to Japan to our allies in the region but
to stand there as I had the privilege to
do at the DMZ and to look into North
Korea for me was it was a it was a
chilling experience to look into a
nation living under the kind of
oppressive regime that the regime family
means in Pyongyang everybody knows that
the best way to get something done here
is through China with China the
president constantly talks about this
relationship he has mushy ching-teng
what are the Chinese doing specifically
that's making the chances of eliminating
this problem well look Weezy yeah and
the president's made it clear we we seek
a peaceable solution here and but the
key is that the message he had me made
clear he had the Secretary of State made
clear and he's made clear is that the
era of strategic patience is over that
now for more than a quarter of a century
the United States has has in one way or
another negotiated had talks waited
patiently all the while we've seen the
regime in North Korea continued its
headlong pursuit of nuclear
weapons and a ballistic missile program
the president said that's over we're
engaging our allies in the region to
economically and diplomatically isolate
but what's really new here I think it's
a great encouragement to people across
this country and across the world is
that you have a president in President
Trump who's engaging directly with the
president of China and we are seeing
China do more than they have done what
your that well we have word of China
turning back coal shipments from North
Korea we have word of them beginning to
reduce the amount of commercial travel
that exists between North Korea but as
the Secretary of State said at the UN
last week China needs to do more we're
calling on our allies in the region to
reconsider their diplomatic relations
with North Korea we're calling on allies
in the region to reconsider their
guest-worker program that provides an
enormous amount of currency to the
regime the key here is for the United
States and our allies in the region
working with China to provide the kind
of economic and diplomatic pressure that
will result in the regime in Pyongyang
ending permanently their nuclear and
ballistic missile ambition that we also
made it clear all options are on the
table and in inactions the world has
seen the president take in Syria and
Afghanistan President Trump in a very
real way has has restored the
credibility of American power and they
know that they know that we are we are
prepared to defend our allies and
ourselves that we're going to drive
toward a peaceable solution we've made
it clear mr. vice president have they do
you have a sense of what they want in
return
from us North Korean yes yes well we I
don't think we do at this point we
continue to see one provocation after
another this this weekend began with a
another failed missile launch from North
Korea even while the world community was
discussing the issue at the UN Security
so how do we get at that to find out
what do you want in return
what what is the whole purpose
I honestly I think North Korea knows
what the world community wants the world
community has been United for know I
want to know what they want what I'm
curious about what their what they want
well they want an end to saying well
well the and I think I think this is a
terrific question because one of the
things Secretary of State Tillerson has
made clear is that under President
Donald Trump we are not going to
negotiate to get the right to negotiate
we're not going to negotiate to get at
the negotiation table
North Korea knows as through UN actions
in the past through pronouncements by
the world community they need to abandon
their nuclear program abandon their
ballistic missile program they need to
stand down in a very real sense to have
the right to engage the world community
on the way forward mr. vice president
can I ask you because Congress finally
reached agreement on this spending
agreement last night so there won't be a
government shutdown but it does not
include money for the wall and it does
continue funding for Planned Parenthood
are you disappointed we couldn't be more
pleased that thanks to president Trump's
leadership and direct engagement last
night the White House and leaders in the
House and Senate in both parties signed
off on a budget deal a little it'll
avert a government shutdown but more
important than that there's going to be
a significant increase in military
spending our armed forces have been
hollowed out in recent years by by
budget cuts 21 billion dollars in
defense spending in this bill there's
also a down payment on border security I
think the American people are encouraged
to hear that since our inauguration that
illegal border crossings are down 60
plus percent in this country and in this
bill there's a down payment on
additional border security I'm also
pleased to see as the president was
insistent on that we're providing
support for health benefits for coal
miners and right here in the District of
Columbia we're continuing an educational
choice program for disadvantaged
children that began back in the days
that I was in the Congress so this is a
budget deal that's a bipartisan win
the American people and the President
signed off on the parameters early
yesterday Republicans and Democrats
reached an agreement with the White
House last night and I think that's a
good piece of of Monday morning families
for the American people Mize yeah
compromises the president told John
Dickerson over the weekend that it's
been a learning curve for the Republican
Party and he said for himself as well do
you feel that well for me it's it's been
just an incredibly humbling experience
to be able to come to this building
every day I serve as vice president a
president Donald Trump but I think for
our colleagues on Capitol Hill
particularly is we continue to drive
toward keeping our promise to repeal and
replace Obamacare as we lay a foundation
for an infrastructure bill for president
Trump's call for the largest tax cut in
American history I think this the
learning process for many on Capitol
Hill about governing has been moving
forward and I think I think this
morning's announcement about reaching a
bipartisan deal on budget says that the
American people can be encouraged that
Washington is working again thanks to
the strong leadership of President
Donald Trump thanks to his direct
engagement with members of Congress
we're seeing real questioners for people
Thank You mr. vice president we are out
of time but thank you I would like to
come to win soon I do thank you so much
for joining us we also want to thank
everyone at the White House including
the communications team the ushers
security and all of the staff who have
been so gracious there helps been
crucial of course in bringing you this
very special broadcast from inside the
East Room a special thanks to to the
entire CBS News crew and DC bureau that
does for us it's been a remarkable time
we'll see you tomorrow from New York CBS
this morning